guillaume vous êtes d'accord avec cela
c'est un peu facile de refaire
l'histoire on a acheté en commun des
vaccins moins cher mais aussi sans doute
avec une livraison plus tard tive et
certains disent qu'on a misé sur les
mauvais laboratoire andres chabat plus
tôt balayé déjà cette question là
largement moi je ne peux pas être juge
pas réputée pour être une très grande
mansuétude en règle générale sur la
commission européenne mais sur cette
question tout à fait particulière je
pense que les choix qui ont été faits
sont plutôt les bons c'est à dire
d'éviter une forme de concurrence entre
les états membres essaient d'éviter au
maximum à une pression sur les prix
parce qu'on sait qu'il est grâce à
certaines indiscrétions et j'y
reviendrai des différences assez grande
sur les prix de ces vaccins donc le
travail qui a été fait de l'offensive
qui a été réalisé par la commission
européenne n'est pas sujette à caution
moi j'ai un reproche fondamental à
l'égard de la commission européenne je
sais que c'est compliqué parce qu'il ya
des questions de propriété
intellectuelle de droit des affaires
mais nous demandons plus de transparence
sur la manière dont était négocié les
contrats sur les prix étant globalement
quel est le lien contractuel qui est
entre l'union européenne et il est les
laboratoires sur le reste je ne pense
pas qu'on puisse faire procès à la
commission européenne d'avoir mal joué
et d'ailleurs les premières tentatives
qui ont été faites très assez tôt entre
quatre pays dont la france dans la malle
italie et lé pays pas si je me souviens
bien d'essayer d'avoir une sorte de de
préférence avec les laboratoires étaient
assez malvenu je trouve surtout
vis-à-vis des états membres qui ont peut
être moins de moyens
le kaiser est très cher je ne suis pas
sûr que tout le monde puisse commander
autant à obtenir autant de doses qu'ils
le souhaitent dans tous les états
membres
en raison de ce prix donc c'était bien
avant une diversité et d'éviter la
concurrence qui aurait été au détriment
des pays est loin fortunés
[Musique]